honestly I feel like I need to take a
dump
[Music]
I'm a little bit nervous I I don't
really know a lot about tarot cards yes
I've gotten Terra red but from like
people who are like into it but not like
they don't do it professionally
I'm so nervous every time I'm nervous I
have to take a dump in a coffee why
don't we start I'm gonna have you pull a
few of these cards we're not gonna turn
them over yet and then I'm gonna just
pull a pyramid reading and just see what
wants to come up you're making me feel
okay I'll be better I'll be better
do I have a few things for you okay that
doesn't look good I mean I'm going on
date with someone but I'm like we're not
like but tell me when is it now we need
to dive into that I haven't had a
serious relationship in a little over a
year like it's been a year and I feel
like I've been really wanting one it's
not showing me the man in here yeah but
are you in a relationship now no okay
good I was like well it's showing me the
card red like she has no idea what's
coming sure look at this yeah new guy
it's showing me a woman who's gonna be
important for you in the future and I
don't I can't tell based on this if you
know her yet someone's coming for now it
just read don't try and like figure
anything out like this is my card worth
like yeah teller did just have fun a new
person enters your life
oh that's sure you ask if that's about
yes yes we should the Sun the Sun when
the upside down is like oh she doesn't
want to be single anymore she's sort of
like ready for the next like she's ready
yeah well it shows me even in
conjunction with this line there was
like a difficult situation so I don't
know if that was someone in the past
that you dated like something that
you're still kind of like releasing but
the way this whole thing reads is like
oh she's finally like having fun again
not time for a relationship yet okay
that's a little sad I don't need to tell
you to date it's not about like you need
to go on all the dating apps and be like
putting yourself out there you Jam
though great I'm telling you we like
this is like the relationship that
you're meant to be in like this is the
card that it's like other relationship
of your dreams they could think they fit
really well together in yeah
this year's not about relationship for
you sorry I'm just gonna have to wait oh
yeah this is it for you is it once this
guy comes in it's it this reads to right
now for you is not about should not be
trying to figure out is this the one
it's like we're helping to heal this
stuff from the past and we just want her
to like enjoy everything now they like
really want to get you ready you see how
I keep playing oh good soulmate card see
you're gonna bite some point you're
gonna get their way down the line after
like 20 cards have been drawn bears the
soul mate
I feel better knowing that way I can
makes me feel like okay you're not crazy
these are not just like wild thoughts
like these are just I mean everything is
valid
I'm a little sad I feel like I've been
waiting for a while for a serious
relationship but I think that's okay you
know
like when the time comes it'll come but
I'm pretty pumped
I mean I'm gonna meet my husband next
year we like him yeah so yeah I'm stoked
[Music]
you
[Music]